i'll talk today about ai monitoring and
explainability and the hidden connection
between these two
topics
when people think about
ml monitoring
deploy the model into
production not you guys but people who
are less technical
they would think of it like everything's
cool
the world is more like that
and there's lots of things that can go
wrong there can be data bugs
data pipelines might be broken the world
might change
you might get one of these pandemics
that we have recently seen can break
things in big ways
you can get new untrained use cases and
shifting concepts and behavior and
adversarial attacks
and all of that
the harsh reality here is that the
moment you put a model in production
it goes on a wild ride
and so monitoring is key
and as we talk about monitoring
the data science teams and the mlaps
teams who operate or install and run
these systems
often struggle to minimize risk and
there's a whole bunch of questions
that come up how can i better understand
how my models are working how do i
identify real problems with the model
what is the problems root caused how can
i debug quickly and how can i make
monitoring work easily in any
environment so those are the three
things that i'll touch on
on the right there
some of the struggles here number one is
with visibility and observability so
that is keeping track of metrics making
sure
when the model is starting to go out of
get haywire
you're getting
alerts you know that you should pay
attention
but that's not where we should end
that's just the first step
the second step is really the deeper
diagnosis root cause analysis
and actionability based on that
though that's kind of the workflow that
i'll walk you through as we go along
with examples
and then the third which is a different
dimension which
the platform folks in the room will
appreciate is that
all of these tools have to fit within a
larger
tech stack and complex
ecosystem and workflow where you have
diverse models you have diverse
stakeholders
so
as we talk about monitoring requirements
there are
a few these are the three different
areas that i just touched on the first
around observability is broad coverage
of model and data quality metrics
that's number one
the next step is to have fast and
precise debugging
and it's the connection between these
two requirements
where you see the emergence of this
connection
between monitoring and root cause
analysis and explainability becomes a
building block for that so that's what
i'll focus on in this talk
there is a whole other dimension on
these kinds of platforms being easy to
deploy and scale
on which i could talk for hours but
that's not going to be the focus of
today's presentation it's the connection
between these two
these two pillars
great so as we get into this connection
this is these are the kind of the top
level questions that i'll walk through
first is just spending some time
understanding how drift happens
which is related to the metrics the
first pillar what are the different
kinds of drift and also being able to
characterize and identify drift that
matters that truly matters for the
model's performance and therefore for
business outcomes that depend on the
model
in the second
section i'll talk about concrete
measures to identify drift and
challenges here
and then we'll go from there into
root cause analysis and mitigation
and and there you'll see that connection
emerge between monitoring metrics and
observability on the one hand and root
cause analysis and debugging on the
other
let's dive in
when we talk about drift
what do we mean
there was a time when bikes used to look
like this
now they look more like that
and if you train a machine learning
model on this kind of data
and then apply it to that kind of data
will it work well it's not a given it
depends quite a bit on what concepts the
model has learned
if it has looked at these
kinds of images and figured that
bikes always have one big wheel and one
small wheel then it will not generalize
well if instead it's looking for two
wheels then it might
so
there is part of the reason that drift
becomes a problem traces its origins to
training data not necessarily looking
like production data
and this is similar to what happened to
models
with kovid
this is an example
of a risk scoring model i'll work with
three examples in today's talk this is a
credit risk model i'll talk also about
the zillow example
and a third example with marketing
models
so in this world this on the x-axis is
the risk score higher scores are
are are indicate more risky individuals
on the y-axis is the density
or the frequency of individuals who have
that kind of risk or in green is the
pre-pandemic data this is from say 2018
and you can see
for people who are processed by this
model there's a distribution of risk
scores
pandemic
that distribution has shifted right
meaning
now the model is viewing
the set of people as more risky on
average
now when that happens first of all you
want to be able to measure it how big is
the drift in the model scores in this
case
and secondly you'll want to understand
why is that happening is the model still
fit for purpose
i'll give you some examples based on
real examples which i i won't be able to
give you the details of the actual
in practice examples but i can speak at
a high level to
give you some indication of what has
been happening
so imagine this credit model where the
risk has gone up a lot post pandemic
now if you can
understand leveraging some root cause
analysis and explainability technology
what are the drivers of the drift
it could be in some cases that the risk
of this set of people have gone up
because their incomes have dropped
post pandemic a lot of people our their
hours went down
as a number especially in the service
sector
because of the pandemic
if that's the driver of the inc of the
drift
and the model is picking up on that and
basing its scores on that
then the model might still be fit for
purpose
if on the other hand it's something else
so for example consider
the scenario where the risk went up
because of differences in reduction in
travel spending
so for example it could be a credit card
company
many of their customers are frequent
flyers historically they see that when
frequent flowers suddenly
reduce spending on airlines that's a
strong indicator of risk
post pandemic a lot of these people may
have stopped flying because they are
concerned about safety as opposed to
losing their jobs
and yet the model is not tuned to the
new reality
so having this kind of view and the
capability to answer these kinds of
questions
can then inform
take you from metrics observability
metrics to the deeper root cause
analysis which can then inform
mitigation in the first case the model
did not require an adjustment
in the second case it would
it would in this case involve
potentially even dropping that feature
or at least reducing its impact on the
model's output
and this does require the data scientist
and a human to be in the loop to have
visibility and have some amount of
domain expertise it goes back to
an important comment that
peter wang made in his talk today
morning
which is one of the big reasons python
took off
was because it was easy to have these
kinds of interactive visualizations
and have visibility into why the models
were working in a way that domain
experts could work with it
so that's one concrete example let me
just give you a few others relatively
quickly
you could have data quality issues for
example broken feature pipelines we have
seen this in the wild a lot
for example
retailers sometimes their pricing models
go out of whack because
maybe they're selling on amazon and
amazon has changed how it's encoding
certain products and the data pipeline
at the retailer has not been
readjusted to reflect that change
you can have
the external world changing the
pandemic example the credit risk example
is one example of that
zillow is another which many of you i'm
sure are familiar with
zillow has lost
like 500 billion dollars now because
their estimation of the prices of homes
were quite high
the world had changed the housing market
had cooled down and they had not their
models had not picked up on them
this was combined with external factors
as well for example that there were
supply chain issues it was hard to get
contractor time
so they couldn't flip the houses as fast
as they expected they would be able to
often these kinds of business outcomes
depend not just on the model it also
depends on what else is going on in the
world
but some of that can get reflected in
the model if your features are
sufficiently expressive
and we have seen this in
other kinds of settings as well with
text data if you trade a model in
wikipedia articles and apply it to news
articles it may not work well we have
seen results from google for example
that
some of the
image analysis models that were
used to do say diabetic retinopathy
analysis when you deploy them in the
wild they don't work so so well
sometimes it's because the scanning
machines are different so there's a bit
of a
context
a concept drift because of that
in some cases the collector trading data
can be quite different so for credit
decisions for example
you may not have labels for the most
recent decisions that you have similarly
for fraud models
so there's a rich set of examples here
which outline some different elements of
how drift happens
so if we get into a to the next level of
detail
the trading data is being used to train
a model to predict a target
and now
you can think of a few different
categories of drift there's data drift
which means that
for example that there's a covariate
shift which means there's a drift in the
input features that are coming in there
can be concept drift where there's a
the relationship between the input
variables and the target variables have
shifted so the credit example i gave
with the travel spending
was an example of a concept drift
the one with the interest rate shift
in the data sorry the income income
shift in the data was more like a
covariate shift so the relationship
still held true between income and
credit worthiness
there can be model decay issues for
example you might have a performance
loss due to a data drift and then there
can also be prediction shift meaning
there could be drift in the model
predictions the scores
of all the drifts that
of all of these kinds of drifts
in the data
not all of them might matter to the
model so when i say consequential drift
i'm referring to
drifts that truly matter
from the standpoint of the model so
imagine this
data distribution in green is the data
from september in gray is the data from
november
they look quite different
and in general when you get to high
dimensional data there is always going
to be some amount of drift in the data
because
it's a high dimensional space and there
will be some differences and they will
accumulate as you look across dimensions
now
if you look though at the
impact of this drift on the model's
output say the model score distribution
or the or the performance related
metrics
it could either be that
this drift matters and the model score
distribution also shifts a lot
as a consequence of that and that's what
we saw in the credit example from a few
slides ago
or it could be that
from the point of view of the model
actually the model score distribution is
very similar
that although this has been some amount
of shift in the data it does not impact
the model's output so imagine that
to give you a simplistic example imagine
that one feature
maybe maybe something like
the age of applicants
for a credit decisioning model shifts a
lot
so the data on if you just look at the
data it'll look like this
but the particular model that is making
decisions does not depend on that
feature much in that case the model
score distribution will not change
and so
you might start getting alerts here
your data drift
metrics might start giving you alerts
but over here you will not get as many
alerts if you are tracking the model
score distribution of metrics
so having more fine grained control here
is useful because you can sometimes
avoid these kinds of false alerts
so so let me give move on to give you a
sense of
how to identify
drift
there are some standard approaches to
measuring drift i'm sure many of you are
familiar
with what i'm going to share
you could measure model performance in
deployment so you have a deployed model
you're keeping track of various accuracy
metrics like genie or auc and f1 scores
and so forth
and you can see that
there these metrics you can certainly
see that these metrics are going down
maybe your marketing campaign is not
working so well suddenly
and the performance is going down not
enough people are clicking on your ads
or uh taking your
coupons
at lyft
so this is an observable
for certain kinds of models this is
observable
you can also compare distributions of
ground truth if you have labels on your
data
then you can see how well the model is
doing
you can compare single input features
you can compare predictions or model
outputs you can also compare full
full data sets
there are a number of challenges though
to applying these kinds of metrics
so
in many cases you don't have ground
truth at least immediately
in order to evaluate model performance
or do this first analysis with ground
truth so imagine a
fraud model or a credit model
there is going to be a delay between
when the model makes the prediction and
when you'll get to know whether it made
the right call similarly with many
pricing models
this is actually very very common
there's a delayed label problem in
machine learning because of which
the
tracking of metrics for observability is
non-trivial certain metrics will be
lagging
behind
if you're tracking things shifts in
single input features then you get to
this problem which i was earlier
alluding to as a consequential kind of
drift analysis
if if there's a say a five percent shift
in some feature does it truly matter
you might get lots of these kinds of
alerts which ones should you prioritize
where should you focus your attention
looking at shifts in the prediction is
great
because
it can tell you that there is a real
impact on the model's output
but does that mean your model has
degraded in the absence of performance
of information
it will not tell you that so you need
that next layer of analysis
to be able to answer this question why
is the prediction shifting so that you
can go on from there to make that
judgment on whether the model needs to
be mitigated whether the model needs a
needs an adjustment
and when you get get to full data sets
then
you start hitting the scores of
dimensionality there's just lots and
lots of features and tracking drift
across all of them
you will get a bunch of metrics but
how do you interpret them how do you act
on them how do you prioritize them
so let me start transitioning now to
okay we are back
did you do some magic
how how do we mitigate a question
i wanted to ask about detection um but
it's clear that
the different ways you laid out what are
the different types of dress they're
very helpful for
concept specifically what will be
yeah
so that's a
great question so maybe let me hold on
to that question because the mitigation
part actually talks about
measurement like like that next layer of
detail on measurements as well as
uh
the root cause analysis so let me come
back to that in a bit
um so maybe this section should not be
just called mitigation it's going to
start showing a bit more detail
and there's not like one answer to that
question right there's a range of
methods for concept drift
okay so one of the things that i want to
kind of leave you with is that
the baseline method often is just
retrain the model as you get new data
coming in just keep retraining the model
with the new data
that
often is not the best answer to counter
drift and i'll share in a little bit
why
what what we would instead suggest you
do is understand the root causes of
drift where is it happening when is it
happening how much is there what is
causing it
and this is the step where the root
cause analysis leverages the connection
with explainability
and then once you understand the root
causes of drift that leads to targeted
ways to address drift
so so let me touch on this a little bit
and we can
look at
look at a few different examples this is
not meant to be exhaustive but just
illustrative
so first you may ask is the drive being
caused what features are driving drift
are they being caused by an unstable
feature
so we are focusing on prediction drift
now this is the example i had towards
the beginning there is a drift in the
model score distribution
the risk the risk scores are started
going up post pandemic
and here are the drivers of drift
the annual income is a big driver
the revolving balance is another driver
as well as
another thing that's related to the
limit so if you think of annual income
in this case
in this case what we could do is
drill down a little bit more and exactly
look at
how the distribution in annual income
has evolved
that's causing the drift in the model
score outputs
and this is the place where we build on
explainability techniques start based on
sharply values
uh and you can lift it from individual
level explanations to distributional
differences
that
level of technical detail i'm happy to
go into more in the q a
but but what that might tell you the
result of that analysis could be
surfacing that
what caused the shift in the model score
distribution is
that annual income has dropped for a
segment of the population in general
when annual income goes down risk goes
up for this model and that was the root
cause of why
the model went model scores went up
now in that case
what you might decide is that the model
is still fine and you the there isn't a
way needs to intervene on the model
other things which we have seen happen i
give you the example of
the travel spending feature which
was the big driver of the
of the increase in risk scores
and that's an example of a concept drift
so
the prediction drift root cause and
analysis the what you're measuring if
you think of the technical work here to
answer your earlier question
in this case
the prediction drift when you look at
its root causes
that surfaces the concept drift
directly because what you can see
through this analysis is
there is a big shift in model scores
increase in model scores
and the root cause of it is a
shift in the distribution of
uh
of of travel spending
where travel spending has gone down to
zero and because of that now the
the this requires the human in the loop
right the human in the loop can look at
it and say
this relationship made sense when we
train the model at that period in time
now it doesn't make sense anymore
because in the current pandemic world
sudden reduction to zero travel spending
does not mean
that our frequent flyer has suddenly
become more risky
um there are a number of other examples
that can come out of this analysis the
other one that i gave you was that of
like in a retail pricing kind of setting
where
suddenly the pricing performance the
performance of the model goes out of
whack when you do the root cause
analysis it comes back to
a specific feature that's the driver and
in that case it was a data pipeline
problem
where
there was an externality the amazon had
changed its encoding
of feature values
and then the internally the pipeline had
not caught up with that
so so those are some some examples it's
not the only way to detect concept drift
but it's it's very powerful and we have
now seen it this kind of analysis play
out really well
so in the case of
in some cases like in that
airline spending example what what
travel spending example what you could
do is to simply
remove that feature without
retraining you could actually
underweight
the impact of that model on the of that
feature on the model's output
without impacting the models
uh without requiring a retraining in
some cases you'll want to retrain
remove a feature and retrain with
existing data so we see sometimes some
of this sometimes also in the context of
fairness analysis where you might have a
proxy for gender or race
or some other protected feature
in the model and
when you see some fairness metrics
go out of back
it can surface that
there is a problem here and you could
sometimes you can address that simply by
eliminating features yeah a question
is
yeah yeah that's a great question so
sometimes the root cause analysis can
show
a diffuse effect where it's not
concentrated all in one feature it can
it can be spread across features and in
fact this kind of analysis also accounts
for feature interactions
that that is very true but often what we
find is with models with hundreds of
features
there are often a few features
under 10 features
which end up being
quite
like the bigger contributors
to
to the drift it's not always going to be
the case
but empirically this is part of our
finding especially with tabular data and
model strain on tabular data
there are often concentrated effects
if the effects are more diffuse then
you'll have to look at
more than the approach will still work
but you'll have to look at then the
analysis will have to be broader so then
you look at 20 features 30 features
instead of just five
no it can work in the context of deep
learning as well because
i'm not sure what you mean by you don't
input features because if you think
about an nlp model there are word
embeddings
the word embeddings are the input
features
yeah that's a great question
you do so what works there is instead of
looking at the input pixels
inside of the deep net
inside of the deep net they learn higher
level features i have some backup slides
i'll have to go into it in the q a but
you can start seeing higher level
features inside of the deep nets and
those start shifting
so there is a different
you can get a very similar kind of
analysis but at like intermediate layers
of the deep network instead of at the
input layer
they can be it depends on the model so
there are some very interesting
connections between robustness of models
and interpretability and their
interpretability where
if you train models with certain kinds
of robustness constraints then
consistently
higher level features that are learned
tend to be much more interpretable so
for faces you the model will pick up on
eyes and ears
and so forth
let me see if i have a oops i should not
have done that
yeah all right
where did it
it's still here
um
will you be able to get it back on my
screen it's still up here
okay got it
all right i'm not so great with
okay is this the is it looking at the
right i can see it
here all right let me see if i have a
slide on that
okay
play from currency
this is what makes orlando bloom or land
of bloom
according to this deep neural network
inside of the network it has learned
concepts like it's it's essentially his
left eye and the lips that's all
everything else is redundant
okay
how am i doing on time sean
ten minute oh wow cool
this is where if you just use something
like integrated gradient to answer your
question it wouldn't work
for the reason that you were saying
right because at the pixel level so some
of you might be familiar with integrated
gradients this is a way to explain
input level explanations for
deep nets so this was the original image
over here let me see this works
this is the original image and its
explanation is showing which pixels in
the image
the network is paying most attention to
this is why
these are the pixels that are the most
important from the standpoint of
of the model of why this is a camera
and then like what you said if you were
to just build on this kind of technology
then
it would be a not a very good analysis
because
there's going to be thousands of pixels
and like most like half of them are
going to be important and that'll not
tell you much
but what i was just showing you is based
on some internal explanation work that
we did at cmu a few years back and
there's related work in the literature
as well which looks inside of the
networks which where the higher level
concepts are learned and you can start
seeing drift at that layer
great
let me see how i'm doing
on the deck
yeah this is i was anticipating your
question so i had a note here saying
topic for q a
great job you set me up for success
so here's a
another kind of so returning to the
concept drift question which was asked
earlier
so one way to
anticipate and deal with concept drift
is that when concept drift is expected
you can translate it into covariate
drift with careful feature engineering
so what you do is that you can add
features to learn periodic change over
time and you can add indicators of
effects or unexpected events and this
might not even need labeling an
additional data so if you go back to our
to our credit risk example with the
covit world
if you have a if you're tracking
something about whether the world is in
covid or not
or if you're tracking other
macroeconomic indicators like
unemployment rate
as part of the features in your model
then certain kinds of anticipated
concept drift can be handled in that way
so one of my co-founders used to work at
uh
at a company that was building
marketing models for retail and search
models for retail
and one of the things he had observed in
his time was that
those models worked really really well
except when they had sales
when the retailer had a sale
the model just went completely crazy
because if you just think about training
one model for both the scenarios and
you're not keeping track of sales using
some kind of special special indicator
like
is sales as a feature in the model
then the sales data gets drowned out
because
this was not like amazon was not one of
their customers so they were not on sale
all the time they only had the big sales
during certain
certain times seasonal events
this could be something that you
anticipate and you track in the model
and if you do
then the expected concept drift during
sale
can get handled through a covariate
drift with feature engineering
for the zillow models also there some of
that is similar
where you could and i'm sure some of
these basic things they would have done
but keeping track of
like
trend variables which are keeping track
of housing prices changing
by region
if that is done well then some of the
prices going down could be tracked and
and and that that could
that could lead if those were tracked in
the model as features then you could
have translated some aspects of concept
drift into covariate drift
another thing is that the drift period
may be too insignificant for a retrained
model to pick up on so this is again
true of the sales world but also lots of
other examples
and finally sometimes no action may be
needed it might be the case that the
model has shifted in a way that it's
still reasonable like
risk going up and income is going down
if that's the root cause of the drift
then the model is perfectly good
so with that kind of background like one
quick thing i'll say is that
when we are monitoring
that involves computing drift on data or
metrics over time
and
this is kind of one way to approach it
you track drift over time you do the
basics look at feature data predictions
if available
look at the ground truth data accuracy
of models
track some of the metrics related to
consequential drift
so future importances distributions of
future importances
there are some other metrics here as
well
and then you can set alerts if the drift
is above a certain threshold that
triggers an alert then you run an
automated root cause analysis and then
you go from there to mitigate
so with that i'll leave you with this
kind of
overview of what we have presented
data drift can happen due to a variety
of internal and external causes not all
drift impacts the model and that's
extremely important it's important to
identify consequential drift otherwise
you'll get overrun with false alerts
there are different classes of metrics
to capture different types of drift
there's features ground truth model
output and relationships
and we also i didn't get into this
bullet here because it's staying away
from our specific product in this talk
but these are the kinds of things that
uh true aeros products help with is also
how to mitigate drift it's not just
about retraining it's important to
understand type and root causes
some in some cases you want to retrain
you want to add
certain kinds of features drop features
do
fairly directed feature engineering
there's data quality issues that can
also get surfaced which need to be
addressed so there's kind of a nice
comprehensive
map of the different paths to
being effective in monitoring and
debugging
and that's at a high level is the
connection between these two pillars
historically a lot of the attention and
monitoring is on metrics and it's
extremely important to have broad
coverage of metrics and custom metric
support and so forth
that by itself is not enough though it's
it's it's critical that you also have
ways of doing fast precise debugging
with root cause analysis and therein
lies the hidden connection between
monitoring and explainability
thank you very much
[Applause]